you definitely want a co-founder
hey this is michael cyball and dalton
caldwell and welcome to rookie mistakes
we've asked yc founders for their rookie
mistakes so we can share them with you
and help you
avoid these common errors let's start
with our first anonymous story from yc
founders and mistakes to avoid at the
beginning when everything's going well
you don't know how you're going to
handle disagreements or bad actions by
the other person it's extremely hard to
deal with a bad situation after the fact
if you don't have anything written down
it's awkward to talk about things like
who gets what percentage of the company
or do you have founder vesting and you
know how human beings are we remember we
don't always remember things quite the
way they went down right
and so write it down
i think the biggest error that i see is
founders looking for someone with a
skill match
versus someone that they actually maybe
have had a fight with before like a
friend a lot of founders assume that
whatever skills their co-founder has at
the moment they join the company are the
only skills they'll ever have
and in my experience almost everything
you learn you learn on the job so you
rather work with someone you really like
and learn together then work with
someone you don't know at all
and uh get into fights and then break up
i mean to put some facts on that how
many founder breakups have we seen
where the founder says my co-founder is
excellent a plus they just don't have
the skills that we need versus
my co-founder is a living nightmare and
i can't take it anymore
right like how many people are like what
a great person that i like a lot they
just didn't end up i shouldn't have made
them my co-founder because they just
didn't have the right skills michael do
you ever hear that
never hear it and by the way it's not
that it's not true it's that that
doesn't cause a co-founder breakup
that doesn't kill a company it's an
error but not a fatal one all right
let's move on to the next one
so
the yc founder wrote in
take arguments with your co-founders
seriously
it's more likely to kill you than
anything else what i see with a lot of
co-founder disputes
is that the relationship has never been
pressure tested they've just been
friends they've been like oh yeah we
we chat all the time and then the first
time there's a disagreement it's just a
blow up
and and the relationship is broken and
you'll never be able to put the pieces
back together again versus if it's
someone you know in a while maybe it
doesn't seem as shiny but you've already
had some disagreements you've already
had the relationship ever ebb and flow
over years right my best takeaway is
that
first you don't always have to come into
a resolution
like if you don't have two people
engaging
uh productively you can pause
you know you don't have to keep the
fight going yeah and then the second one
is like understanding how your
co-founder deals with stress
like some people deal with stress by
attacking
some people deal with stress by
retreating and like if you understand
how your co-founder deals with stress
you can kind of
better interpret what they're doing
all right here's the last um
here's the last comment that ayc founder
wrote in
i chose a co-founder with whom i could
not share my honest disagreement
we didn't know how to fight well or come
out of those fights better and wiser
some part of that was conflict avoidance
on my part and some part of that was him
fighting dirty
it's crazy when you speak to founders
where
they'll spend eight hours a day with
someone
and
12 hours a day with someone and they'll
be like
i haven't spoken to them in a week
like like wait you know
and i'm like what what are you guys
doing all day like you haven't talked to
him in a week um or i haven't talked to
him in a month or i haven't had a i've
had a real conversation with them in a
year and i think when things get that
bad
i would argue there's a point where
breaking up becomes inevitable
and the ceo's job is now not
how to repair the relationship it's
basically how to
separate
in like the most effective and least
destructive way
when you talk to folks about this
they know in their hearts that that's
what needs to happen but they just can't
bring themselves to actually do it
because it
feels bad
and so that's what again when you talk
to these folks they know they know
that that it makes the right thing for
the company is is to go their separate
ways but they for whatever reason
they're willing to go through years of
pain or actually reduce the chance the
startup's going to work than to face
that head-on it's it's really rough the
longer this relationship persists in
this way before there's a breakup
the worse
the breakup is going to be like the more
likely there's litigation they're more
likely there's
you know
one person has vested stock so now your
cap table's affected like they're all
these things that get worse by leaving
it alone
how should the ceo set up a company so
that if this battle
you know if there is a co-founder fight
it's it's not fatal to the company the
closest to equal you can get the better
because it avoids this oh this person
has 10 percent more so it's their
company you see all this drama that
happens over equity split so
equal is good however here's a pro tip
for you
a straight 50 50 deadlock
is rough and we see that kill companies
a lot and so it might be reasonable
for the ceo to have one extra share
so you effectively have the same
ownership your equal co-founders but
that one extra share is you agreeing in
writing early that in the event of a
50-50 deadlock
there's a tiebreaker vote dalton before
we close
what are some tactical tips you give
folks who are looking for co-founders
now who are extremely early in their
journey or thinking about starting a
company
i hear from a lot of folks starting
companies where they want to come up
with the idea first maybe they want to
raise money first and then they want to
add a co-founder and i actually think
that's going about it
in a less than ideal way and actually
might cause more problems okay i would
recommend figuring out who the
co-founder is first and then if you come
up with the idea together
and perhaps you fundraise together then
you'll have collective ownership that
it's your idea and it's your company
versus a lot of times when you add
co-founders later
in their mind it's your company
it's not their company and even though
you know you worked on the company an
extra month than the other person did
which is so silly right you'll always
have this like well this wasn't my idea
this wasn't my company
um which isn't great from a retention
perspective if you can both really feel
like you shepherded the idea through the
earliest stages you're going to see a
lot more ownership and people stepping
up when you go through hard times to
reiterate what we talked about at the
beginning
um
i don't want to say co-founders are
essential
but man they're so helpful it's such a
powerful tool
especially in the hardest part of the
startup the pre-product market fit
startup we still encourage everyone to
have a co-founder
um but like the startup game right it's
not about doing it well it's about doing
it great like having a great co-founder
can be a super power for your company
um
having an okay co-founder not taking
this seriously
can be the seed of big problems
absolutely and sometimes people they end
up with co-founder issues i'm like well
i guess i'm just going to quit and start
a new company and we'll well well it's
so easy to start a new company and then
it's like well good luck and then you
speak to them a year or two later and
it's
really hard to get back to where they
were in the moment and one of the
regrets is they wish they would have
spent the time
to set up the co-founder relationship
well and choose the right person first
then think they can just
blow everything up and get a do-over
that's just not how life works and so
the more you can front-load this the
first time around versus having hard
earned lessons
yeah would recommend
yeah yeah
so we recommend you get a co-founder we
recommend you do it well
we recommend that you invest in that
relationship early
so that you can survive the fights that
will inevitably happen
and
man grab this superpower like you should
certainly get a co-founder but
don't slack
don't slack off this isn't the place
where you want to slack off where you
want to put 50 effort like this is one
of the most important things you're
doing in the beginning of the company
you